[Musik]
darum hält mit ganz unterschiedlicher
ist zum teil 2 gefolgt wo gerade da wo
messi und co
ich habe direkt beim wasserfall später
hgm herum standort verschiedene 11 und
voller wo bäume oder der nadel der
größten stadt der usa ist schauen rät
man von allen guten geistern verlassen
alle guten geister hier der schamane
lebt in einer welt zu der ich wie wohl
die meisten menschen keinen zugang habe
wenn einer steine am wegrand grüßt ist
der fall klar der spinnt doch was kann
ich lernen wenn ich mich auf den
schamanen einlassen
mit neugier stadt arbon das versuche ich
in diesem film
[Musik]
hier bedarf steige ganz nach am
wasserfall verstärkt beachtung sehr
schätze der kaliumgehalt der verheerung
mit dem wasserfall mitte veh
[Musik]
ein schwieriger start als wäre es
selbstverständlich zeigt mir schauen
rüttimann wo die faust
da auf diesem vorsprung
man kenne sich schon gut er und die fee
sie helfe ihm wenn ihn fragen zum leben
brauchten
es war jung geschädigt
das tradition hält das habe ich das von
machen das ja dass das ist schon gesehen
so verrückt das klingen mag dies ist
keine show für die kamera die
feinstoffliche welt ist charlotte manns
realität
mir fehlen klare definitionen und
konkrete antworten
vieles bleibt unscharf für mich als
journalist eine ungewohnte situation
[Musik]
der schamane wo und ganzen tag über
ganze vom tod ist sie zurück ist aber so
wie ich das alte motto hat vor der
gewalt der sich als brücke zwischen
gewalt und alltagswelt wird partie
es musste irgendwie krieg vor bevor der
gangster welt wollen das strand und
scharbeutz macht und nana vater war
charlotte man lebt in münchen bei
schwarzenburg
der 59-jährige ist biologie laborant und
arbeitet als bakterien spezialist in der
lebensmittelindustrie in seiner freizeit
mit vielen perdu hält er sich hier an
streng wissenschaftliche regeln für mich
ein krasser widerspruch wenn mir jede
spirituelle wald um tour natur weil es
war es für kunststück vollbringt die
braucht es um somit die schiene wieder
mit ganz einfach you ganz pragmatisch
ist
juli angesetzt charlotte man arbeitet 70
prozent die übrige zeit verbringt er in
der geisterwelt
[Musik]
er wandert zu seinem ganz persönlichen
kraft orten die er in jahrelanger arbeit
ausfindig gemacht habt wie hier auf den
geistlosen beim jantos
[Musik]
heute ist sommersonnenwende der längste
tag des jahres
so wird jemand sagt er spüre die präsenz
der naturgeister jetzt besonders aktiv
seien
er bedankte sich bei ihnen für eine gute
erste jahreshälfte
ganz am anfang vor verdampfer manischer
weg ist ist das für mich fast der not
sie also ja immer wieder der natur und
harry tradegate mit seichtes dass sie
nicht nur mehr einfach bissiger fantasie
um hand ihres und das wirklich ja
hannovers hat das ganze ja viel zäher
überholt frühere massivster punkt mit
erfahrung kann ja mit 40 zweiter sie zum
beispiel im letzten teil wo beim rufe
sie ist mir ein wachhund aufgefallen wo
ja wieso nicht mit grad sonst ist sie
aber doch
starke präsenz kann hat sie mir
verschiedene steine aufgefallen wo ja
aber irgendwie bleibt sie belegt die
shoa wie die naturgeister sie relativ
ortsgebunden und darum aber sonnenstein
wo er schon verkauft hat ist natürlich
[Applaus]
schwierig sehr gute musik für den sonne
natur geist und die denner zwischen sind
begeisterte hey ya machine die am
ehesten jetzt inzwischen im bostoner
gibt der für die vielleicht mal opfer
machen oder was für das opfer so john
berry oder süsterseel ich lieber nix am
liter oder also wie sie wisse dass das
begeisterte ja das
die energie oder gar die pro täglich aus
wie gerade so 2
das sehr gern
natürlich entbehren zwerge die gerne
käse essen jeder vernünftigen grundlage
natürlich kann charlotte man nichts
beweisen
aber warum sollte er diese dinge
erfinden
er ist stets allein unterwegs und
verdient mit dem schamanismus keinen
rappen
die antwort ist so einfach wie editieren
er zeigt mir seine welt seine realität
das zeigt vor der pflanz liga betrug für
rituale aber erstmal katar hatte blühte
und dann spielst wohin geburt immer
wieder statt flach männlich mit
verschiedenen feine sache wo menschen
verstehen von deponie sondern endlich
wieder mit großem garten
sie singt dass wir stark das sieht zwei
stehen jetzt da von dieser klasse hat
[Musik]
passend für das master ritual wo selbst
ritual von adobe macher
[Musik]
die streifzüge des schamanen richten
sich nach dem keltischen kalender anfang
august feierte lukas hat das fest der
freundschaft und verbundenheit zwischen
der geisterwelt und der alltagswelt
die verbundenheit wieder so ne
verbundenheit mit dem fall kann
das tier war mir wieder zeichen ergibt
ob wir auf dem richtigen weg wie und was
die passen die passende verhalten ist im
moment da ist es wieder das vage das
unfassbare sein verehrter folge aber
auch bäume und steine für den schamanen
ist alles beseelt er ist ein natur
schwärmen er ist eine sinne in
jahrelanger arbeit zur höchste
achtsamkeit geschont hat
das ist dieses mandana wo mineral rief
lanze und dierig verbindet und werk von
der münze hat platzt sie dann dass sie
wiederum merklich unter druck steht am
schluss sein aber da hatte ich hier und
die kosmische energie verbunden auf die
oft japan i
[Musik]
die sogenannte einweihung zum schamanen
hatte er vor 30 jahren die schmerzen
einer schweren stirnhöhlenentzündung
trieben ihn fast in den wahnsinn
er fiel ins koma also wieder aufwachte
war er ein anderer mensch der
schamanische weg noch vor ihm
nach der krankheit bin ja erst moment
trägt iv revision vor der überzeugung
von der kraft und dem tisch lag sie ja
das ist nie weit und im laufe der woche
hat sich das natürlich wieder klemmt
oder es ganz deutlich verblasst
das jahr zwei fleischer und das ist
schon gut so bin ich von a tour bus
selbstkritisch und antonio gerne in
frage stellen und umso mehr angemietet
in frank stellte seit jahren das jetzt
mal ob es erlaubt viele topstars habe
hast mir jetzt helfen
juli die jetzt schon
es geht nicht möglich
der schamane sagt einen teil seines
wissens habe er direkt von der
geisterwelt empfangen
zusätzlich studierte er die schamanische
literatur
[Musik]
existiert zwischen himmel und erde
wirklich nur das was wir sehen
und warum empören wir uns wenn einer
sagt er sehe mehr aus wir sehen und
zwerge
auf meinen streifzügen mit charlotte man
wird mir klar es geht gar nicht darum ob
es solche wesen wirklich gibt es geht
darum zu respektieren dass jeder mensch
in seiner eigenen realität lebt
zum erntedank ende september besucht der
schamane einer kraft trotzdem hilfe
hier treffen sandstein nagel flug und
kalkstein aufeinander und sorgen für
besondere energie
[Musik]
ich beobachte scharri team an und frage
mich wo sich unsere welten berühren
wir teilen die begeisterung für die
natur könnte es nicht sein dass der
schamane dieser begeisterung einfach
blumigen namen gibt als ich dass die
feier auf dem felsvorsprung nichts
weiter ist als die manifestation eines
glücksgefühls hand sie führt zu einer
friedlichen sie das beschrieben dass
diese partie gegen jahr fast zur familie
mitglied dass sie zum teil auch
persönlichkeiten wo mir sehr nach
strafft ihre wir nun noch nicht so an
sängerin bonnie zum zu setzen sowie von
bier und danach und so
[Musik]
am zweiten februar feiert der schamane
lichtmess die rückkehr das licht nach
den dunklen wintermonaten
[Musik]
er will die grosse geld in aus der
unterwelt locken damit sie die
fruchtbarkeit fördere
[Musik]
zwei räucherstäbchen ein pinsel
die drei ist die zahl der ertappten
[Musik]
ist der schamanismus sie betrieben
flucht vor der realität
es ist frank ide realität ganz im
gegenteil aber nie mit dem schamanismus
sowie der bezug zum einfachen aber bezug
zu der einfache elemente die deponie in
hier und jetzt verankert
das einfach also gnome fair und elf
gehöre jetzt landläufiger zur realität
ja das ist dass ich schon da aber das
universum vor der schamane wo einfach
nach einer kommuniziert mit messern aber
nicht für jedermann sichtbar sie für sie
gehört das alles zu der realität das ist
ja wie vor der natur für für mich im
allgemeinen securities spezielles als
schamane das ist für mich natürlich und
aber die wasser es ist einfach eine
weitere dimension vor formal tat
[Musik]
ein jahr lang habe ich charlie thiemann
begleitet er hat mir die augen geöffnet
für die wunder der natur geister habe
ich keine gesehen
wobei ist diese wunderschöne eisblume
wirklich nicht mehr auf gefrorenes
wasser
[Musik]